todesfahrt in trier in der fußgängerzone
fährt ein mann zahlreiche menschen an
mindestens vier sterben der hintergrund
ist unklar
das rennen und den corona impfstoff auch
bayon tag aus mainz hat die zulassung in
der eu beantragt und erwartet sie noch
in diesem jahr zwischen hoffnungen
bangen die nato-außenminister setzen auf
den neuen us-präsidenten und fürchten
dass der aktuelle in afghanistan noch
fakten schafft
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend wir kommen bei
den heute nachrichten um 7 den sport hat
norbert lehmann dabei guten haben durch
von mir für eine stadt in deutschland
ist dieser dienstag ein schreckenstag in
trier ist am frühen nachmittag ein suv
in die fußgängerzone erfasst mehrere
passanten verletzt sie schwer
mindestens vier sterben offenbar
darunter ein kind
ein bild des grauens habe sich geboten
sagt der oberbürgermeister
der fahrer ein 51 jähriger deutscher aus
dem raum trier er wird festgenommen
nach angaben von augenzeugen fuhr der
mann fast einen kilometer lang durch die
fußgängerzone unweit des wahrzeichens
von trier der porta nigra rettungskräfte
aus der ganzen region waren im einsatz
um die verletzten zu versorgen
anna duda fasst zusammen das auto raste
durch die vorweihnachtlich geschmückte
fußgängerzone in trier menschen liegen
am boden werden notärztlich versorgt
andere laufen noch hilfesuchend umher
umgestürzte ständer umgefahrene tische
und stühle
wir sehen solche bilder im fernsehen
ganz oft und denken das kann bei uns
nicht passieren jetzt ist es auch in
trier passiert die simeonstraße eine
belebte einkaufsstraße die vom stadttor
der porta nigra bis in die trierer
altstadt führt ins chaos gestürzt
ein großaufgebot der polizei und
zahlreiche rettungskräfte sind in der
stadt unterwegs die lage zunächst
unübersichtlich kürzester zeit innerhalb
von minuten haben sich hier enorme
mengen und polizisten zusammengezogen
also es war auch sofort ein hubschrauber
in der luft er das wohl kontrolliert hat
nach etwa 800 metern verfolgungsjagd
habe man den mutmaßlichen täter gefasst
so die polizei ein 51 jähriger deutscher
aus dem landkreis trier saarburg die
polizei nahm den mann fest stellte das
silberne fahrzeug sicher der mann soll
allein im fahrzeug gesessen haben
was wir bisher wissen ist dass ein
autofahrer aus richtung konzert in
straße in die brotstraße ein geboren ist
dann durch die gesamte fußgängerzone
gefahren ist bisher ans ende porta nigra
unterwegs wahllos menschen angefahren
hat die polizei spricht von mehreren
toten und einer ganzen reihe von
schwerverletzten
es ist eine bedrückende stimmung hier in
dieser stadt und das ist einfach nur
schrecklich wenn man an die angehörigen
der opfer denkt die wirklicher von klar
ich auf nichts sozusagen aus dem leben
gerissen worden sind aufgrund dieser
schrecklichen tat
am abend soll es im trierer dom ein
gebet für die toten und verletzten geben
susanne gelhard ist für uns in trier
susanne die pressekonferenz von stadt
polizei und feuerwehr hat gerade erst
begonnen
aber was weiß man jetzt schon etwa zum
motiv des fahrers
die polizei geht davon aus dass es kein
politisches motiv gibt das ist das was
wir bisher erfahren haben zuvor war ja
schon durchgedrungen dass man von einem
einzeltäter aus geht und die polizei hat
die vier tote bestätigt darunter auch
ein kleinkind
mindestens 15 verletzte soll es gegeben
haben darunter schwer verletzte wir
stehen hier vor der fußgängerzone von
trier und hier kam um 13 uhr 48 der
erste notruf zur polizei hier fuhr der
mann fast einen kilometer ganz offenbar
gezielt menschen an bevor er dann am
ende der fußgängerzone von der polizei
gestoppt und festgenommen wurde
normalerweise sind hier viele menschen
unterwegs zu weihnachtseinkäufen um
diese zeit auch kunden aus den
nachbarländer luxemburg und frankreich
man kann also sagen in diesem fall haben
die korona maßnahmen ihr gutes bewirkt
dass es nicht noch mehr opfer gab
über die motivation werden vielleicht in
den nächsten minuten noch erfahren
auf der pressekonferenz der polizei die
jetzt noch andauert ja genau und weil
sie noch läuft sprechen wir gleich noch
mal in der sendung mit ihnen danke bis
hierher
aktuelle informationen zu den
dramatischen vorgängen in trier finden
sie auch in unserer zdf heute app dort
fassen wir jederzeit zusammen was
die lage bekannt ist bei der korona
impfstoff entwicklung geht es momentan
schlag auf schlag
neben dem us-konzern mit werner haben
auch die deutsch amerikanischen partner
bayon tag und weise eine zulassung für
ihren impfstoff bei der eu
arzneimittelagentur beantragt und das
genehmigungsverfahren soll zügig
weitergehen teilt die eu behörde immer
mit die entscheidung über den ersten
corona impfstoff wird ende dezember
erwartet
über die vorbereitungen der anbieter und
die geplante verteilung von cobit 19
impfstoffen berichtet anselm stern
spritzen die die krise beenden das ist
die große hoffnung eine hoffnung die
wächst weil die forschung fortschritte
macht in rekordzeit heute beantragen
auch biontech und pfizer offiziell die
impfstoff zulassung in europa so weit
werde zulassung gehalten also sei es
dann irgendwann in europa oder in den
usa als je nachdem die behörden
entscheiden werden können wir innerhalb
von wenigen stunden ausliefern sagt der
finanzvorstand von bayern tag gemeinsam
mit der forschungsministerin
die bundesregierung wird auch alles
unternehmen um die bürgerinnen und
bürger um die vorteile der impfung
aufzuklären und um es noch einmal
deutlich zu sagen die impfung bleibt
freiwillig wann tatsächlich die freigabe
kommt für die allerersten anti corona
impfdosen darüber entscheiden sie hier
bei der europäischen arzneimittelagentur
beide wirkstoffe die geprüft werden
haben gute zahlen vorzuweisen moderner
94 biontech weiser 95 wirksam und
offenbar auch gut verträglich es gibt
relativ häufig leichte nebenwirkungen es
kam aber bei diesen beiden mrm stoffen
zu keinen schweren nebenwirkungen von
daher würde ich sagen die daten die uns
bisher vorliegen zeigen dass dies
möglicherweise sehr sichere impfstoffe
sind damit die sicher ankommen bei den
menschen werden derzeit sogar stadien zu
in zentren wie hier in düsseldorf
wir haben vereinbart zwischen bund und
ländern dass die impfzentren ab mitte
dezember einsatzbereit sein sollen stand
heute ist mit der zulassung eines
impfstoffes rund um den jahreswechsel zu
rechnen dann wartet eine menge arbeit
der impfstoff muss gekühlt gelagert
verteilt und verabreicht werden die
nächste mammut aufgabe in dieser krise
ja und wie diese mammut aufgabe
bewältigt werden soll wann es losgeht
wer geimpft wird und vor allem wo und
wie lange es etwa dauern wird bis ein
großteil der bevölkerung durch geimpft
ist um all diese fragen hat sich
christoph distel gekümmert
spätestens ende dezember soll es mit dem
impfen losgehen bis dahin will die
zuständige eu-behörde die ersten
impfstoffe freigeben was dann folgt
scheint theoretisch klar zuerst kommen
ältere und risikopatienten dran
außerdem medizinisches personal und
andere systemrelevante berufsgruppen wie
lehrer oder polizisten praktisch aber
kann sich niemand spontan beim nächsten
impfzentrum in die schlange stellen
das wird nur mit attest gehen
wahrscheinlich vom hausarzt
dann kommt die logistisch größte
herausforderung nicht nur die millionen
pixar in den impfzentren sondern vor
allem die aufklärung unmittelbar davor
individuell für jeden einzelnen all das
wird teuer
beim impfstoff etwa rechnet bayon tag
mit 15 euro 50 pro dosis zahlen werden
aber wohl bund und länder
sobald mindestens 60 prozent der
bevölkerung durch geimpft sind sollte
das virus in schach seien 100.000
impfungen pro tag hält das archiv für
machbar
das wären rund anderthalb jahre bis zur
herdenimmunität zum impfen entschlossen
ist gut die hälfte der deutschen knapp
30 prozent überlegen noch 20 prozent
wollen nicht mitmachen so oder so
normalität wird es auch im nächsten jahr
definitiv nicht geben um die pandemie
kurzfristig in den griff zu bekommen
gelten in den meisten bundesländern seit
heute verschärfte chor ohne regeln
so dürfen sich unter anderem nur noch
fünf personen aus maximal zwei
haushalten treffen die infektionszahlen
bleiben derweil hoch das robert koch
institut meldet heute 13
604 neuinfektionen mit corona binnen 24
stunden das sind 50 mehr als vergangenen
dienstag die zahl der toten in
verbindung mit 19 stieg um 388 mit am
schlimmsten ist die lage seit über einer
woche im landkreis hildburghausen in
thüringen
zwar ist die zahl der neuinfektionen
leicht zurückgegangen aber sie liegt
aktuell immer noch bei 519 pro 100000
einwohner in sieben tagen im landkreis
gelten deshalb besonders strenge coroner
regeln kitas und schulen sind
geschlossen
damit sie wieder öffnen können hat
hildburghausen heute mit einem
freiwilligen massentest begonnen daniela
sonntag
anna sophia war das erste kind das heute
morgen in hildburghausen getestet wurde
[Musik]
ist ergebnis negativ darauf hatte ihre
mutter gehofft weil ich möchte man gehen
wieder in den kindergarten kommen und
ich denke warum sollte man so einen
abstrich nicht nehmen 25 teams von rotem
kreuz thw und bundeswehr sollen schulen
und kitas unterwegs sein ziel die
einrichtungen schnell wieder öffnen
vor allem aber soll der freiwillige
massentest klären ob schulen und kitas
tatsächlich infektions treiber sind
was wir wissen ist wie viele positive
fälle habe ich konkret an einer
einrichtung wie in quarantäne fälle habe
ich dort konkret aber wie es dann
wirklich aussieht mit denen die
sozusagen nicht getestet worden
das ist die dunkelziffer die man mit
diesem test doch immer eruieren kann
doch diese massen momentaufnahme ist
auch umstritten manche kommunen im
landkreis machen nicht mit
in hildburghausen selbst gibt es ohnehin
viel skepsis gegenüber den strengen
corona maßnahmen bislang hat hier nur
ein drittel der eltern kinder zum test
in den städtischen kitas angemeldet muss
jeder für sich selber entscheiden einer
kleinen maus dahingehend wie kriegt so
ein stückchen in die lager geschoben
weiß nicht
bis zum 4 dezember soll die aktion
laufen 8000 kinder und 1000 pädagogen
dürfen mitmachen die hoffnung die daten
reichen um die verbreitung von corona
hier besser zu verstehen
die auswirkungen der korona maßnahmen im
november sind auch auf dem arbeitsmarkt
sichtbar
so wird etwa kurzarbeit stärker in
anspruch genommen trotzdem die zahl der
arbeitslosen ist im vergleich zum
oktober gesunken
im november waren zwei millionen 699.000
menschen arbeitslos das sind 61 1000
weniger als im monat zuvor
die arbeitslosenquote lag bei 5,9
prozent im vergleich zum november
letzten jahres gab es 519000 arbeitslose
mehr
mit der wolfs brigade 44 hat
innenminister horst seehofer wieder eine
neonazi vereinigung verboten
die gruppierung die auch unter dem namen
sturm brega 44 auftrat bekannte sich
offen zu adolf hitler und wollte wieder
einen ns staat errichten
am morgen wurden wohnungen mehrere
vereinsmitglieder durchsucht waffen
hakenkreuze und speichermedien
beschlagnahmt
nach brüssel zur nato die will sich
reformieren
die außenminister beraten heute virtuell
gleich ein ganzes bündel von vorschlägen
außenminister heiko maas verspricht sich
eine zitat frischzellenkur für das
westliche verteidigungsbündnis und mit
blick auf den gewählten us präsidenten
joe biden ist die hoffnung auf ein neues
europäisch amerikanisches zusammenspiel
groß stefan leifert berichtet zu den
letzten hinterlassenschaften der ära
trump droht ein vorzeitiges ende der
nato-mission in afghanistan zu gehören
fast die hälfte der 4500 us soldaten
will der scheidende us-präsident bis
januar ohne absprache in bündnis
abziehen
bei der nato geht es jetzt um
schadensbegrenzung und darum die mission
zu retten kann ist dann braucht
sicherheit und frieden und die rechte
der bevölkerung die in den letzten
jahren so mühsam errungen worden
wir müssen bewahrt bleiben in diesem
prozess und um das erreichte abzusichern
dürfen wir deshalb jetzt nichts
überstürzen
die sorge ist groß denn die amerikaner
liefern in afghanistan fähigkeiten die
kein anderes land auf die schnelle
übernehmen könnte es ist das erste nato
treffen seit der us wahl zusammen mit
dem künftigen präsidenten will die nato
nicht nur stabilität ins bündnis bringen
sondern sich selbst reformieren
fast 140 reform vorschläge einer
expertenkommission liegen seit heute auf
dem tisch darunter die empfehlung das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip abzuschaffen das
oft lähmt mit der eu enger
zusammenzuarbeiten und sich stärker mit
china zu beschäftigen
verdiente traumhaus kommen die zeit ist
gekommen um das strategische konzept der
nato zu aktualisieren
darin wird sich widerspiegeln dass sich
die sicherheitsarchitektur auf der welt
fundamental geändert hat momentan
changed fürs frühjahr plant die nato
einen gipfel mit dem künftigen
us-präsidenten die reparaturarbeiten am
transatlantischen verhältnis haben
begonnen
beiden wird kein bequemer partner für
die europäer aber ein verlässlicher und
berechenbarer nicht alles wird anders
aber vieles besser so die gefühlslage in
brüssel
und jetzt noch einmal zu susanne gelhard
in trier wo heute ein suv fahrer in die
fußgängerzone gefahren ist mindestens
vier menschen getötet und viele schwer
verletzt hat susanne was gibt es neues
von der pressekonferenz
man habe ein klares bild von dem
verdächtigen heißt es jetzt bei der
polizei
es ist vielleicht auch der grund dafür
dass man sich relativ schnell festgelegt
hat dass die tat kein politisches motiv
hat man bleibt bei der zahl vier tote
der jüngste das jüngste opfer ist neun
monate alt das älteste 72 jahre
die zahl der schwerverletzten wurde mit
4 angegeben und dutzende weiter
verletzte
da gibt es keine genaue zahl die polizei
hat hier sehr schnell reagiert vier
minuten nach dem ersten notruf wurde die
der täter gestoppt und festgenommen
700 polizeikräfte waren hier insgesamt
im einsatz aus dem ganzen land und der
täter wird oder der tatverdächtige wird
noch verhört wir hoffen dass wir im
laufe des abends noch mehr informationen
bekommen
vielen dank bis hierher susanne gelhard
ja und jetzt ganz anderes thema
zdf-intendant thomas bellut ist mit
einem emmy ausgezeichnet worden
eine jury in new york verlieh ihm den
directorate award 2021
der preis würdigt seine leistungen als
medienmanager und die rolle des zdf
während und nach der wiedervereinigung
mit dem international emmy directorate
award werden einzelpersonen oder
organisationen für ihren herausragenden
beitrag zum internationalen fernsehen
ausgezeichnet und jetzt blicken wir noch
auf den mond gemeinsam mit 1,4
milliarden chinesen
denn je 5 hat es geschafft die sonde
benannt nach der chinesischen mondgöttin
ist gelandet
sagen jedenfalls die offiziellen in
peking aktuelle bilder gibt es noch
nicht lange soll kostbare mitbringsel
zurück nach hause bringen mondgestein
das haben bisher nur russen und
amerikaner geschafft
tja und sondiert und zur
fußball-champions champions league oder
sind die deutschen vereine ja gut im
rennen allerdings heute müssen bayern
und gladbacher borussia mönchengladbach
empfiehlt empfängt als überraschender
tabellenführer der gruppe b den
überraschenden tabellenletzten inter
mailand ein sieg heute abend und
gladbach stunde vorzeitig im
achtelfinale im hinspiel schaute man
noch in getrockneten gladbacher
gesichter nach dem späten ausgleich der
italiener
sechs wochen später gibt borussia
selbstbewusst in das neue duell
wir wissen um die situation in der wir
uns aktuell befinden wir haben davor 4c
musik spielte schon gezeigt dass wir
sehr hohe qualitäten haben
das gilt es jetzt morgen auch wieder auf
dem platz zu bringen nur noch drei
punkte trennen sie vom ersten
achtelfinale nach 43 jahren dann würden
die gesichter sicherlich fröhlicher
ausfallen
ja und die bayern die sind bereits für
das achtelfinale qualifiziert und werden
heute abend beim spiel in madrid gegen
atletico einige stars zu hause lassen
dafür bekommen nachwuchsspieler eine
chance operation jugend forscht ist
gestartet bei den bayern zwangsläufig
denn viele leistungsträger sind nicht
fit die menge an spielen ist hoch es ist
so dass leon goretzka angeschlagen ist
und auch levi robert lewandowski ist
angeschlagen und wenn jemand nicht bei
100 prozent ist dann dann bringt der
mannschaft mannschaft nicht zu viel
eine veränderte aber nicht geschwächte
mannschaft wird das seien gegen atlético
madrid in der auch manuel neuer eine
pause bekommt und durch alexander nübel
ersetzt wird aber zu verlieren gibt es
ja nichts bayern schon sicher im
halbfinale
madrid will gewinnen denn es geht um
platz zwei und damit das weiterkommen
bayern sicher im achtelfinal bis zum
halb firma dauert es noch ein bisschen
formel 1 pilot lewis hamilton ist
positiv auf corona getestet worden und
wird deshalb am sonntag beim vorletzten
saisonrennen in bahrain nicht dabei sein
weltmeister ist der erreger bereits
dramatische rettungsaktion mit happy end
bei der härtesten einhandsegler
segelregatta der welt wohnen die glut
mit-favorit kevin s kopie aus frankreich
hier noch vor der havarie meldet
wassereinbruch in seinem schiff und das
r sinke bei eisigen temperaturen im
südpolarmeer wird es kofi von landsmann
rune kam gerettet schwere stürme mit
meter hohen wellen bringen die einhand
segler immer wieder in gefährliche
spektakuläre bilder von dieser monti
blog jederzeit bei uns zu sehen
gerne schnee gab es heute morgen in der
mitte und im süden des landes ob
vielleicht bald neuer kommt dazu gleich
mehr von katja hornuf ab so viel von uns
für den moment das heute journal um
viertel vor zehn mit claus kleber
wir danken für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
wünschen noch einen angenehmen abend bis
morgen um dieselbe zeit
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
pünktlich zum meteorologischen start in
den winter hat es geschneit jetzt liegen
in den mittelgebirgen zum teil elf oder
zwölf zentimeter und im flachland im
süden häufig 1 bis 8 cm und dieser
schnee bleibt in der nacht auf jeden
fall liegen denn die temperaturen sinken
doch meist auf 0 bis -6 grad im
nordwesten bleibt es etwas milder aber
da liegt ja auch kein schnee ist kann
auch in dieser nacht noch hier und da
glatt sein
an den alpen fällt noch etwas schnee und
westlich des rheins ist doch etwas regen
unterwegs
es gibt zum teil auch dichten nebel
morgen gibt es ein deutliches
west-ost-gefälle was die wolken und was
den sonnenschein anbetrifft in sachsen
strahlt morgen die sonne aber auch
zwischen der ostseeküste und der donau
sehen sie häufiger mal sonne im westen
dagegen bleibt es recht trüben das ganze
bei einem leichten bis mäßigen wind aus
südöstlichen richtungen
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen im
westerzgebirge im vogtland und dem
thüringer wald so bei minus vier grad am
niederrhein wird am mildesten mit bis zu
sechs grad und in den nächsten tagen
geht es doch winterlich weiter dabei
beschränken sich die regen schnee regen
und schneefälle doch im wesentlichen auf
den westen
schönen abend noch